the archive field notes are one of the
really major contributions that Joseph
Grinnell added to the field of
scientific Natural History and Museum
science when he became director here he
says that the real value all were doing
now won't be found it and won't be known
until a century to come
what we want to do is not only compare
our findings today with what Grinnell
saw a hundred years ago but establish
baselines for repeat surveys at periods
of 20 and 20 year intervals or something
like that for the future so that if we
see changes we can get a better handle
on monitoring the rate of change about
fifty percent of the mammals have
experienced a range shift and the range
shifts there are three kinds there are
low elevation species that have had
their upper elevational ranges expanded
upwards by an average of about fifteen
hundred feet there are high elevation
species that have had their lower
elevational ranges retracted upwards
again by a Biden an average of 1500 feet
and then there are a couple of species
that have actually gone the reverse
there are high elevation things that
have expanded downwards one in
particular called the montane true so
about half the small mammal fauna has
changed its distributional relationships
along the gradient about half hasn't
changed at all so of the species that
have shown the most dramatic range
shifts the Alpine chipmunk is the one of
the high elevation species that has
retracted the most this is a species
that has disappeared from tuolumne
meadows for example and it now occurs
about 1,800 feet higher than where it
used to occur and you have to get really
up into the high country almost a 10,000
feet before you find it anymore it's
also an endemic to California as
California is only endemic mammal
basically as only known from the central
one and southern Sears and so if it
continues to march upward it's going to
disappear because it's going to get
pushed off the top of the mountain so
it's a species of someone who's
concerned the low elevation species that
has expanded its upper range most is a
thing called the pinion mouse that's got
huge years
it's really obvious when you see it this
is an animal the expanded all the way up
to above 10,000 feet right to tree line
almost in the whitebark pine zone so it
is really shifted its at both its
elevational range and its ecological
range my field notes for this bus my
ninth of october eight of october here
we are on a south slope of williams
butte in Mono County which is just to
the just south of Lee Vining and I'm
describing how I got there and where
this locality is I'm providing a map as
to where my trap lines and so forth are
and I'm providing photographs of the
habitat this is opinion juniper woodland
which is the characteristic habitat of
this animal on the east side this is one
that we're working with a lot this is
the lodgepole pine chipmunk because it's
one of the species that hasn't shifted
its range at all and so one of the
questions is why is and its sympatric at
its higher elevational ring with the
alpine chipmunk so they both used to
occur and quite commonly in tuolumne
meadows and this is the only one you
find there now so one of the questions
to ask is why has this one not changed
why is that not experienced any shift
while something that it was sympathique
with lived in the same basic habitat
with shifted enormously my name is emily
rivage I'm a fourth-year graduate
student here in the museum and I'm
looking at genetic changes in two
species of Chipmunks over time one of
the questions she's asking is has there
been a change in has there been a loss
of genetic diversity as a result of
these kinds of population retractions
because if they've lost genetic
diversity then they've lost to some
degree the capacity to adapt and
genetically over the long run and so
that's she's
it's another value of those of having
the specimens because she's able to
extract DNA from the museum skins of the
Grinnell era and actually determine what
the pattern and levels of genetic
diversity were a hundred years ago and
matched that that what we observed today
what we've done is go back has gone back
in and digitized all the original field
notes and they're now all online so if
somebody wants to go read what Joseph
Grinnell was actually thinking about on
a particular day when he was out in the
field you can go to his notes in and
read it july twenty-fifth nineteen
fifteen sunday the lord hath sent us a
wolverine and the setting a number three
steel traps Ferris and I set out on the
19th on top of a ridge between mcclure
fork and Lyle fork at 11,000 feet animal
was found this morning was caught by all
three traps struggled let heard no sound
but occasional grunts struggled
violently and bit the stock off the gun
you